un petit établissement saint pierrois ou
planche consciencieusement un bon
millier d'élèves
nous sommes dans le lycée ambroise
vollard de terre-sainte son originalité
c'est le seul du département a formé aux
arts appliqués
il y aurait il donc un rapport entre
cette section et ambroise vollard ce que
vous savez qu'il était en brasse vollard
noms suivants dans un lycée qui portait
son nom un dernier on avait plein de
voix en dessus que je suis trop
feignants pour la pratique est d'abord
un réunionnais con artist
c'était un patin amis des artistes un
mécène
collectionneurs marchands de tableaux
sur effet
énormément de peintres contemporains un
éditeur un marchand de tableaux est un
écrivain voilà
fils de notaire ambroise net à saint
denis en juillet 1868 grâce à un prêt
d'honneur il part à montpellier suivre
des études
mais c'est à paris qu'il poursuit son
droit pas très longtemps puisque le
jeune au vert 26 fait à l'esprit
ironique se découvre une passion pour la
peinture
après avoir vendu un dessin signé
forains trois fois plus cher qu'ils ne
l'avaient acheté il ouvre en 1890 sa
propre galerie d'art rue laffitte à
paris il y expose l'avant garde de les
paul cézanne renoir gauguin picasso van
gogh ou encore matif il devient l'ami de
ma main qu'il fait reconnaître grâce à
ces critiques
il se lie avec de nombreux artistes qui
font sa fortune et redistribue le succès
ainsi gauguin en océanie touchent une
pension c'est de sa rencontre avec
alfred jarry hauteur du père ubu que se
révèle son talent d'écrivain
ambroise vollard à une plume il
s'inspire du personnage d'ubu et rédige
une série d'ouvragés insolent il se fait
aussi éditeur et publie des recueils de
poèmes talentueux illustré de peintres
fameux le 23 août 1939
le réunionnais annonce sa mort dans un
accident de voiture il laisse une
magnifique collection que sa famille a
légué au musée léon dierx